Guten Morgen Lino. Guten Morgen Tim.
Meinst du, das war eine äh eine Sendungsmanipulation?
Die haben uns gehackt.
Logbuchnetzpolitik Nummer zweihundertundvier heute garantiert Russenfrei. Ach nee, doch nicht.
Wieso? Rust.
Tim, thematisch, thematisch müssen wir das, glaube ich, sicherlich anschneiden.
Du kriegst nichts mehr ohne Russe heute. Der Russe ist überall schon drin.
Ja, ja. Früher hieß es immer den die Russen kommen und so, die.
Der Russe.
Ja, die rote Gefahr und was nicht alles oder der Russe.
Es ist halt so ein bisschen was von von achtziger Jahre, nur mit verschobenen Feindbildern so auf beiden Seiten, weil jetzt irgendwie sowas irgendwie zusammen oder nicht, man weiß es ja nicht. Also die Großmächte.
Geben ein strenges Bild ab. Aber das soll nicht unsere Leitlinie sein heute bei Lokbuch Netzpolitik, sondern heute wollen wir uns auch mal wieder ein bisschen auf ein paar andere äh Themen,
konzentrieren, werden gleich wieder das ein oder andere aufnehmen müssen und äh auch wollen, nämlich etwas Feedback zur letzten doch eher etwas ausführlicheren Sendung.
Und äh eine andere Tradition haben wir dann auch mal wieder aufleben lassen. Wir haben nämlich mal wieder einen Gast und begrüßen den Ingo. Ingo. Dachwitz.
Und dich kennt man vielleicht vom äh deiner Schreiberei auf Netzpolitik org, du bist ja einer der Autoren. Äh wie lange machst du das schon.
Äh ich habe in diesem Jahr angefangen seit Mai schreibe ich äh bin ich quasi der Angestellt und schreibe da.
Aber du hast vorher auch schon geschrieben, oder?
Nee, ich habe ehrlich gesagt vorher gar nicht geschrieben, äh die ich bei Netzpolitik jedenfalls. Ähm ich war vorher bei der oder bin immer noch bei der DG gegessen, aber vorher als studentische Hilfskraft quasi bei der Diges gearbeitet.
Genau daher kennen wir uns auch schon länger und du bist der äh vor allem denke ich auch äh bei den Dickiges-Leuten bekannt als der regelmäßige Moderator des Diges Abends.
Genau, ich hab die große Freude einmal im Monat am ersten Dienstag im Monat den netzpolitischen Abend der Diges in der Seabase zu moderieren.
Ja, den haben wir ja hier schon mindestens einen, wahrscheinlich sogar schon mehrere Male herausgehoben. Kann ich auch nochmal machen, aber ich bin auch nach wie vor äh ziemlich beeindruckt, wie lange läuft das denn jetzt? Seit fünf Jahren, ne, oder?
Also es ist der fünfundfünfzigste, ich war ehrlich gesagt ja in den Anfangstagen noch nicht dabei.
Ja, sind fünf Jahre geteilt durch elf. Ne, weil Dezember ist ja nichts. Ähm
Ja und es gilt auch nach wie vor das, was ich letzte Mal gesagt habe, ich bin immer wieder erstaunt, wie viele Leute da immer kommen, egal wie das Wetter ist, also es ist immer immer brechend voll und es wird auch irgendwie nicht weniger. Und auch das habe ich schon mal gesagt und wiederhol's gern.
Ich sehe da Leute, die ich sonst so nicht unbedingt,
See, so. Also ähm das das überrascht mich. Man wird ja gerade von so einem Abend immer erwarten, dass da so äh ne man unter sich ist und äh schön zu den konvertierten äh gepredigt
wird, aber dem ist nicht unbedingt so.
Genau, das ist auf jeden Fall natürlich ist jetzt auch eine Komponente, dass man da irgendwie die Leute trifft, äh aus der Szene quasi, dass da irgendwie einen festen Ort,
und einen festen Zeitpunkt, wo man sich trifft, aber es sind echt äh auch immer wieder Leute dabei, wo man ähm jetzt mindestens optisch, aber auch wenn man mit denen spricht, quasi dann denkt, huch, äh ist ja äh mal sozusagen jemand ähm,
der sonst nicht immer dabei ist. Ähm.
Und je nach Thema ähm kommen dann echt auch Leute wirklich, die mitkriegen wenn ein besonderes Thema irgendwie ansteht, die dann echt für so ein Thema daherkommen, ne,
Ähm das ist ja eine echt coole Plattform.
Ja heute wollen wir mal nicht ganz so viel Zeit äh verbrauchen auf die Sendung, da fällt uns heute auch der passende Zeitrahmen dafür. Ähm die Neus haben wir nicht so ein bisschen äh Feedback.
Ja, wir haben äh ausführliches Feedback natürlich bekommen, einmal zu, also zu beiden großen Themenblöcken in der letzten Woche. Das war ja einmal ähm,
Die DRX Kurs in die Psychologie und einmal der Exkurs in die Telekom. Fangen wir mal an mit der Telekom, da war eine äh eine der zentralen Fragen, die da noch in den Kommentaren aufkam, welche welche Route wurden denn jetzt gehackt? Und ähm.
Da hab ich mich deshalb nicht so zu geäußert, weil ich da mir nicht ganz im Klaren bin, was die offizielle Lage ist und was die inoffizielle Lage ist. Also ähm,
Es gibt Berichte und Gerüchte darüber, dass ähm DeLinkgeräte und,
Züchse, Seiksellgeräte betroffen wären und es gibt vor allem Berichterstattung darüber, dass in dem Vereinigten Königreich ähm.
Ein Provider namens Talk Talk betroffen
sei. Interessanterweise finde ich da offiziell Berichte darüber, äh dass der dass es da auch zu Ausfällen gekommen sei. Inoffiziell höre ich da noch ganz andere Berichte. Und ähm
Deswegen will ich da irgendwie nicht jetzt so ins Konkrete gehen, was man in den, man kann in den Medien lesen, wo andere betroffen sind. Sagen wir mal so, wer die Geräte, die infiziert sind und es werden welche infiziert sein. Ähm,
Die haben wir auf jeden Fall jetzt die die wunderschöne Schwierigkeit, dass der, dass dieser Exploid als allererstes eine Firewall-Regel setzt, um diese TR null sechs neun Schnittstelle zuzumachen
ja? Wenn man sich das äh Binary runterlädt und einfach mal mit Strings drauf schaut, ist das auch so mit das erste, was man sieht, dass eine IP-Tables-Regel äh geschrieben wird, wenn ich mich recht erinnere.
Das heißt äh du kannst den du kannst sie als Provider jetzt nicht ohne Weiteres so einfach wieder zurück
Flächen ähm hatte ich glaube ich in der letzten Sendung auch erwähnt. Also es gibt,
auf der Welt jetzt irgendwo Provider, die mit ganz großen Schuhen äh ganz große Feuer austreten und es gibt darüber einige Gerüchte hinter vorgehaltener Hand, aber ich weiß nicht genau, wie viel davon jetzt offiziell ist.
Ähm fand ich aber auch nicht so nicht so interessant oder
für für deutsche Netzpolitik jetzt nicht so interessant. Ähm ich habe ja schon lange genug über die Technik letzte Mal gesprochen und das Feedback war einerseits, dass es dass es zwar gut erklärt habe, von anderen Leuten kam auch das Feedback, dass sie nach drei Minuten vollständig den Faden verloren hat.
Ja, da das ist äh ähm das das hatte wirklich Feedback äh Potential auch so im Gehörgang.
Es gab zu dem ganzen Thema noch ein äh ein größeres äh Treffen im Bundeswirtschaftsministerium, wo Frank Rieger und ich auch als Vertreter des Chaos-Computerclubs dann zugegen waren, um da ein bisschen die
die Lage zu beurteilen.
Ähm und da sind nur noch andere interessante Aspekte zur Sprache gekommen. Zum Beispiel ähm was auch bei uns in den Kommentaren zur Sprache kam.
Ähm dass da ich irgendwie Festnetz nicht benutze mir gar nicht so, weiß ich gar nicht so mit Berichtenswert fand, aber da die Telekom ja die ganzen ähm Router auf Voice over IP umgeschaltet hat, äh funktionierte auch die Telefonie dann nicht mehr.
Damit auch kein Notruf.
Und damit auch kein Notruf und das ist natürlich ein größeres Problem
noch ein größeres Problem als ein Internetausfall rein rechtlich und Verfügbarkeit und so weiter. Äh und dazu kommt der,
die ärgerlich, amüsant, traurig, weiß ich nicht, Fügung, dass ähm eine der frühen
Empfehlungen, die ja ausgesprochen wurde, den Nutzern war, schalte doch deinen DNS-Server um, auf den von Google.
Was das hat die Telekom gesagt.
Nee, das hat nicht die Telekom empfohlen, sondern die Computerbild äh war wohl der oder also es, ne, war die, die es dann abgeschrieben haben und in die in die breite Masse getragen haben.
Ähm da könnte ich sagen, das, das könnte was fast von mir sein, denn die Folge davon war, das Internet ging wieder, aber der Telekom DNS gibt dir nicht die löst nicht auf, die internen Namen, die der ähm,
Die der Voiceover IP äh die das Voice of IP Setup von der deutschen Telekom braucht. Das heißt, wenn du jetzt deinen Speedford Router umgeschaltet hast.
Hast du zwei Internet, aber kein Telefon.
Also zu Ende aber kein Telefon. Und ähm.
Was auch was muss man aber auch sagen das darf gar nicht möglich sein so etwas so zu verkonfiguieren. Das.
Also da es gibt also offenbar jetzt oder es gab da das Problem mit einigen Leuten, dass sie kein Telefon haben,
Alles After-Maf, wir haben eine neue Woche mit mit neuen Problemen, die wir uns gleich widmen wollen und ähm,
ja äh die Empfehlung, dass ich noch einen Podcast über IT-Security mit einem noch einen Podcast, über Psychologie mache, äh nämlich äh gerne entgegen und wenn ich dann endlich meine Petition durchhabe, dass der Tag sechsunddreißig Stunden kriegt, ähm dann können wir das auch irgendwann vielleicht nochmal
Angriff nehmen, aber ansonsten muss ich ja irgendwie auch noch.
Zwischendurch was anderes machen. So, dann haben wir zu dem äh haben wir zu dem Datensammeln und der Wahlmanipulation durch Daten sammeln ein.
Einen wichtigen Hinweis, den ich einfach auch in der letzten Sendung vergessen habe, denn äh der ist von
von AD. Mich wundert diese Diskussion zu Psychographic Votertargeting schon etwas.
Die letzten beiden Kampagnen von Obama als große Big Data Erfolge gefeiert wurden
und meinem Verständnis nach genau das getan haben. Das basierte auf einer intensiven Wählerdatensammlung durch die Kampagne, die bei uns wohl ein Skandal wäre und da kann man, glaube ich, nur zustimmen.
Ja, das glaube ich auch. Ähm ich weiß jetzt ehrlich gesagt gar nicht, ob's der,
Erster Wahlkampf von ihm, da ging's ja vor allen Dingen so stand vor allen Dingen so im Fokus das Thema Social Media und wie er es genutzt hat. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob da auch schon die
große Datensammlung schon so eine Rolle gespielt hat, aber spätestens der zweitausendzwölfer ist ja immer gefeiert worden, als hier guck wie Obama's Nerds äh die Wahl gewonnen haben. Ähm äh weil sie so viele Daten hatten über die Wähler.
Ja ich weiß aber nicht genau, was so die Premierequelle war. Ich glaube äh ich meine der wesentliche Aufhänger war ja jetzt, dass diese Daten quasi eher so als ähm,
So als Nebenprodukt äh des normalen Netzverhaltens erzeugt wurden und nicht nur so eine reine Datensammlung, wie sie ja ohnehin schon immer in den USA möglich war, dadurch, dass eben so viele privaten Daten dort einfach äh zum Verkauf anstehen durch Unternehmen et cetera,
ich glaub das berichtigt auch jetzt hier nochmal die zusätzliche Aufregung in diesem Fall, dass man halt einfach Verhalten abgreift und nicht einfach nur normales äh Datenaufkommen sammelt.
Das stimmt und ich glaube, ihr habt's letztes Mal auch schon gesagt, in Europa beziehungsweise in Deutschland kann man vielleicht an der Stelle auch nochmal dazu sagen, wäre das rechtlich so, ja, einfach absolut nicht möglich. Wir haben, ich habe irgendwie vor anderthalb Wochen schon mal die Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte angeschrieben, was die denn eigentlich dazu sagt, da habe ich jetzt gestern eine Antwort bekommen
und werde vielleicht schreibe ich da heute auch nochmal eine Kleinigkeit zu, einfach um nochmal deutlich zu machen, die Regeln in Deutschland beziehungsweise Europa lassen das eben nicht zu.
Bindung.
Dann kann das auch nicht passieren.
Einem Satz, was was denken, würdest du sagen, ist so primär das Verhindernde Element, weil ich meine ist ja nicht so, dass alles was verboten ist, äh, nicht auch gemacht wird.
Das stimmt. Ähm also ich glaube einer der zentralen Punkte ist ja wirklich das Thema Zweckbindung. Also eigentlich, dass Daten ähm nicht also so zweckentfremdet werden dürfen, ähm wie es jetzt da in den USA geschehen ist. Also vor allen Dingen ja, dass die Daten, also auch diese
von Cambridge Analytica gesammelten Daten ja irgendwie durch Spiele irgendwie gesammelt worden sind und die dann letztendlich für einen ganz anderen ähm also Spiele oder Persönlichkeitstest und dann für einen ganz anderen Zweck verwendet worden sind. Ähm da sehen die Regeln in Deutschland zumindest einiges vor.
Ähm also es wäre natürlich technisch möglich, aber es ist halt ähm sozusagen erstmal nicht erlaubt. Genau. Dann ist ja alles gut.
Na ja, das bestimmt nicht, aber.
Ja
Wir bleiben bei der Wahlmanipulation. Ähm also Wahlmanipulation ist das große Thema.
Ähm einen Teil, den wir in der letzten Sendung noch nicht so ausführlich besprochen haben, war der der Fake News. Also es ist, es krassiert gerade das Thema, äh dass ähm,
durch Fake News, also als Fakt dargestellte äh nicht Wahrheiten.
In ihrer Verbreitung zunehmen und äh somit auf die Politik eingewirkt würde ins so dieses Wort postfaktisch ist doch glaube ich jetzt auch Worte,
Wort des Jahres geworden, also eine Politik oder eine Welt, die sich.
Abseits der Fakten bewegt und damit nichts mehr zu tun hat. Das heißt, wir scheinen das Zeitalter,
verlassen zu haben, in der Politik und ihre Entscheidungen sich noch wirklich an Fakten orientieren. Ich glaube, das ist ein bisschen ähm äh
Vielleicht auch ein bisschen übertrieben, aber äh wir wir sehen auf jeden Fall diese Tendenzen, dass Politik mehr mit Emotionen gemacht wird und wenig Fakten orientiert stattfindet
Und ähm das Thema wurde jetzt immer größer oder hat jetzt so seinen Höhepunkt in damit das in Deutschland zumindest. Damit das Renate Künast eine Strafanzeige gestellt hat. Weil jemand auf Facebook schrieb.
Ähm also es gab einen Mordfall in Freiburg, war das einer oder mehrere.
Grausamer Mordfall, großes Thema in Freiburg, Angst in Stadt, in Angst und Schrecken ähm großflächige Gentests und so weiter, haben dann am Ende dazu geführt, dass ein,
oder wurden auch durchgeführt.
Wurden auch durchgeführt. Er war ja mhm. Aber es war ein Haar, was am Ende ähm entscheidend war. Genau. Aber nicht entgehen, nicht die Genanalyse davon.
Genanalyse der Studierenden äh hatte dann nix gebracht, ne?
Ja, nee, sie haben ein Haar gefunden und das Haar hatte so eine auf der einen Seite eine blondfärbung.
Und auf der Basis hat dann tatsächlich eine Polizistin, also ganz klassische Polizeiarbeit in der Straßenbahn jemanden gefunden, der halt so auch sonst ins Profil passte, inwiefern da jetzt noch die Genanalyse vielleicht doch nochmal eine Rolle gespielt hat, weiß ich nicht, aber da hat irgendwie was gepasst,
und äh explizit diese auffällige Haarfärbung war dann sozusagen der Schlüssel zum äh Erfolg laut dieser.
Berichterstattung bisher.
So und das Ergebnis war, dass es sich damit dabei um eine geflüchtete Person handelte. So, das äh.
Ist natürlich in heutigen Zeiten in Deutschland eine Nachricht mit Sprengkraft.
Weil ja die ganze Zeit davor gewarnt wird, dass die ganzen Leute nach Deutschland flüchten, um hier die Frauen zu vergewaltigen und zu töten
und das hatte natürlich egal wie du über so eine Nachricht berichtest oder auch nicht berichtest.
Gibt das richtig Feuer, ne? Die Tagesschau hatte sich dann entschieden, darüber nicht zu berichten.
Ähm und hatte dann natürlich sofort die Lügepresse Schreier ähm am Hals. Ähm hat dann, es gab einen äh B
von Kai Gniffke, dem Chefredakteur der Tagesschau, der dann darin erklärte, entschuldigen wir äh also Mordfälle gibt's die ganze Zeit, da berichten wir normalerweise nicht drüber. Es sei denn, die haben besondere Relevanz,
und ähm schrieb dann auch gleichzeitig, dass sie das Thema aber jetzt in den Tagesthemen dann doch bringen, weil es ja jetzt dann doch relevanz hat. Also da.
Hat mal gesehen, die Tagesschau hat sich da dran, die Finger verbrannt, alle möglichen Leute haben sich daran die Finger verbrannt, das ist eine Nachricht mit Sprengkraft und natürlich dann auch eine Nachricht, die mit Fake News äh verbunden wird, weil nämlich dann jemand auf ähm.
Auf Facebook Renate Künast,
Angeblich aus der süddeutschen Zeitung zitierte mit den Worten der traumatisierte junge Flüchtling hat zwar getötet, man muss ihm aber jetzt trotzdem helfen. Und nannte dafür als Quelle die süddeutsche Zeitung,
Das ist auf mehr in mehrerfacher Hinsicht.
Perfide, weil die Süddeutsche Zeitung seit kurzem ein EdBlocker hat, das heißt viele Leute können die ein Adlerblocker hat, das heißt viele Leute können diese Nachricht bei der Süddeutschen Zeitung noch nicht mal mehr verifizieren.
Äh zweitens erinnern wir uns, dass Renate Kühners nachdem ein ähm,
Ein Mensch in einem Zug, ich weiß nicht mehr genau in welcher Stadt das war.
Irgendwo in Bayern glaube ich, ja.
In Süddeutschland ein ein Mensch mit.
Mit der Axa losgegangen ist.
Datesiert, dann die Frage gestellt, warum die Polizei den erschossen hat.
Und dafür relativ gut ein Abbekommen. Wir hatten das auch hier kurz am Rande.
Hatten wir Thema.
Gute Social Media Strategie war. Ähm, insofern diese diese Fake News reiht sich quasi auch damit etwas ein, ist relativ relativ geschickt platziert, muss.
Ja, ja, die linksgrünen versüften.
Ja, die ja sowieso.
Kommentatoren und so.
Auf jeden Fall da dagegen hat sie jetzt eine Strafanzeige erstattet und das Thema ist jetzt groß. Ähm, die Sozialdemokraten haben dann irgendwie gesagt sie sie setzen auf ein nichts ein nicht Angriffspakt aller Parteien, dass man so etwas nicht machen wolle.
Würde.
Was natürlich ganz schön ist, aber der Typ, der diese Nachricht da geschrieben hat, ist ja im Zweifelsfall auch nicht in einer Partei. Ja, also die Parteien, selbst wenn die Parteien einen solchen Nichtangriffspakt unterzeichnen und ähm
das dann selber sich in solchen Bereichen nicht engagieren, also inklusive.
Auch Social Bots einzubringen, dann können das natürlich trotzdem immer noch gelangweilte oder wütende Bürger tun.
Ja, es geht dabei natürlich auch immer um die AfD in erster Linie, ne? Und äh da ist eben bekannt, dass
die teilweise auch sagen, wir machen's nicht und da ist als Partei dann eben offiziell nicht machen, aber natürlich Leute aus ihrem Umfeld, äh beziehungsweise aus ihren Netzwerken haben, die das dann eben machen. Also, da ist dann echt die Frage, was ist es wert, dass es dann eben
oder was wäre das wert, wenn sie jetzt so ein offiziell nicht anderes Pakt gäbe? Natürlich, also sich erstmal dazu bekennen, ist wichtig, damit man Leute im Zweifelsfall dann auch verurteilen kann, wenn man's nach oder.
Damit man's beurteilen kann, wenn Leute es dann nachgewiesen machen, aber helfen dürfte das eher nicht.
Vor allem kannst du ja auch, wenn du jetzt irgendwie einer, wenn einer Partei dir besonders gut gefällt, dann kannst du ja sogar einfach ein ähm eine Fake Book News oder Bot-Kampagne für eine andere Partei machen, um dann am Ende äh die Öffentlichkeit darauf hinzuweisen,
was weiß ich, die SPD den Angriffspakt verletzt hat, ja? Also das wird da wird noch so viel.
Hat ja auch nichts mit der AfD zu tun, ist ja was ganz anderes.
Ja, aber der wird auf jeden Fall noch eine ganze Menge ähm also da wird noch eine ganze Menge Pingpong gespielt werden und und mit Täuschungen und äh und so gearbeitet werden.
Da muss man doch mal was gegen tun.
Genau, da muss man mal was gegen tun. Ähm irgendwelche Christdemokraten hatten dann auch sowas gesagt, sie wollten irgendwie so eine so eine Bundesprüfstelle für Wahrheit oder sowas etablieren oder so. Ich ich weiß nicht.
Roh ein Wahrheitsministerium.
Verbot von von Falschmeldung. Ja. Hatte so ein CDU CSU Bundestagsabgeordneter gefor.
CSU, ja k.
Wahrheitsministerium, das wollten wir schon immer mal haben. Neunzehnhundertvierundachtzig reloaded. Das ist echt geil.
Das ist echt geil, ja? Das das.
Ja an der Stelle kann ich einfach nur auf den Artikel äh von meinem Kollegen Markus Reuter verweisen, der einfach sehr großartig ist, weil er äh quasi so ein paar oder eine ganze Reihe rhetorischer Fragen an diesen Bundestags.
Stellt und gleichzeitig darauf verweist wie auch CDU oder Unionspolitiker mit falsch,
Meldung, Fake News gearbeitet haben quasi. Also verweist dann so auf solche Beispiele wie das ist. Ähm.
Dass die Bundesregierung gesagt hatte, es sei nicht geplant oder es gäbe keine Nebenabrede zum Thema ähm.
Bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, dass sie äh Informationen, Daten dann auch an Geheimdienste weitergegeben werden dürfen, die ist ja nachweisbar dann doch gab ähm und ja demon demontiert das ziemlich gut.
Ja, das ist wirklich eine es ist natürlich tragisch. Ich meine, wir wir alle beobachten das mit mit großer Sorge, dass irgendwie diese Falschmeldungen rasieren und irgendwie äh wirken. Andererseits sind natürlich alle äh wirklich ein.
Irgendwie juristischen oder legislativen Maßnahmen dagegen äh wirklich sehr äh,
sehr bemitleidenswert, eigentlich sehr, sehr traurige Versuche, die alle in die falsche Richtung gehen werden. Ich wurde ähm war ja dann noch dazu kam, dass der Russe die Wahl manipuliert,
dann morgens aus dem Bett geklingelt vom vom Deutschlandfunk und wurde dann gefragt, ja was was kann man denn tun? Da musste ich dann auch eine Sekunde überlegen, aber also im Prinzip,
Also wirklich kannst du dagegen nichts tun. Wenn du jetzt anschaust, was die Renate Kühners gemacht hat, die hat ähm.
Dieser Falschmeldung enormen Auftrieb verliehen, dadurch, dass sie dagegen vorgeht. Das heißt, sie hat da ein bisschen mit dem Strahlsandeffekt Bekanntschaft gemacht. Gleichzeitig aber natürlich schon auch.
Hoffentlich es geschafft für den größeren Teil der Leute klarzumachen, dass sie, dass das nicht stimmt
Das geht aber nur einmal, ja? Der nächste Bundestagsabgeordnete, der irgendwie eine Strafanzeige gegen eine Fake News stellt, der wird diesen medialen Effekt nicht mehr erzielen und ähm Gefängnis werden ja auch viel zu viel.
Äh gestreut, als dass du ernsthaft dagegen vorgehen könntest, auch.
Wenn man das jetzt unter Strafe steht, da ging's ja irgendwie so unter Strafestellen von Falschmeldungen zur Destabilisierung des Staates oder sowas, ne. Das ist eine hohe, hohe Hürde. Äh da da hast du ja monatelange äh Ermittlungen am Ende und dann einen Freispruch und diese Fake News sind in dem Moment ja schon längst verdaut, ja.
Also da, ich, ich denke, man ist da tatsächlich mit mit klassischen juristischen Mitteln einfach machtlos und auch wenn man sie zensieren würde,
wäre man machtlos, weil der das genau das ist, ne, dass die etablierten Medien, die dizensieren uns jetzt auch noch. Wir dürfen das nicht mehr sagen, ne,
die Lügenpresse verbietet uns die Wahrheit zu sagen, wir werden zensiert. Also auch da wieder nur Wasser auf den Mühlen, ähm.
Ich wollte das noch kurz am Rande erwähnen, ich wurde mir auch gefragt, also was was kann man was kann man äh den Politikern raten jetzt zu tun und meine Empfehlung war, ja es ist
Politiker sollten sich ernsthaft jetzt mal überlegen, ob sie nicht mal ein bisschen ähm ehrlicher und offener sind ähm und äh
einfach mal ein bisschen transparenter agieren, weil wenn es denen demnächst so geht wie einem John Podesta. Ich glaube, da werden im gesamten
Bundestag nur wenige Politiker stehen bleiben wenn ihnen eine solche äh,
Offen eine solche Entblößung durch Leaks widerfahren würde. Ihr seht, ich äh schwanke gerade hin und her zwischen Leaks und Fake News, aber das ist war da bei dieser bei diesem Thema auch der Fall.
Ja, es muss auch nochmal, glaube ich, wert, äh, diesen, diesen Begriff, der jetzt hier aufgekommen ist, nochmal ein bisschen zu hinterfragen, einige haben ja auch kritisiert, oh Gott, jetzt nennt ihr das Fake News, aber das ist ja eigentlich Propaganda und das sind ja, äh, muss ja auch unterscheiden zwischen
gefälschten Nachrichten, aus welchen Gründen auch immer und irgendwie am aktiven
Ziel, was dahinter steht, das ist natürlich alles richtig, in gewisser Hinsicht fanden wir Fak,
bis vor kurzem ja auch total lustig, weil da kam das nämlich eigentlich von Seeonien oder in Deutschland vom,
Postillon und da war das irgendwie Satire und äh auch Titanic et cetera. Also es ist ja auch schon immer eine eine ähm ein Stilmittel der Kritik
immer gewesen, nur dass sie quasi dann am Ende in der Regel ja doch schon versucht hat klar zu machen, okay, das war jetzt mal hier Tank and Sheak und äh denkt mal drüber nach.
Stellt euch doch mal vor, äh das wäre jetzt wirklich so, das ist ja ein unerträglicher Zustand und das hat sich halt jetzt gewandelt in so eine, ja, wir sagen jetzt einfach mal, das wäre so und versetzen euch in Angst Angst und Schrecken und wahrscheinlich ist es äh schon mal
ganz hilfreich. An der Stelle äh auch eine andere Sprachregelung zu finden, dass man das nicht zu sehr unter diesem Gummibegriff ähm
abspeichert, aber wie das eben so ist im Newsycle. Wir werden das jetzt auch nicht so ohne Weiteres loswerden, ja? Der Begriff steht als solcher, eben für verschiedene äh Trends. Ansonsten würde ich mir äh,
dir auch anschließend minus sicherlich ist es jetzt ähm,
Erforderlich eine, ich sage mal, eine andere Wahrhaftigkeit an den Tag zu legen. So, das äh
könnte schon helfen, aber es ist natürlich auch etwas, was nur Mittel und langfristig äh Erfolge erzielen wird.
Dann wurde ich noch gefragt, was könnten denn die äh Medien tun? Das war äh das fand ich ganz interessant. Das einzige, was heute eigentlich.
Welche Medien denn jetzt die Mainstream-Medien.
Jetzt habe ich die die Lügenpresse. Ja, weil habe ich auch irgendwie kurz darüber nachgedacht, habe mir überlegt, eigentlich das Einzige, was.
Die Ware, die echten Medien jetzt noch machen können oder die die nennt man die denn überhaupt, ne? Sage ich mal, die die.
Etablierten Medien.
Die sich der.
Die sich der ich will jetzt nicht Objektivität, aber wie würde man das sagen? Faktizität, die Faktenbasierten Medien.
Das Einzige, was sie wirklich tun können, ist sich Mühe geben, komplexe Sachverhalte gut.
Zu erklären, damit die Leute auch die komplexen Antworten auf diese Sachverhalte noch verstehen und sich nicht jenen zuwenden, die möglichst einfache Antworten äh propagieren. Was besseres fiel mir nicht ein.
Ja, ich finde in dem Zusammenhang vielleicht noch ist ein bisschen anderes Thema, aber gehört auch wieder zu das Thema Social Bots ist ja jetzt irgendwie vor zwei Wochen war das, glaube ich, irgendwie, wo das jetzt das große Thema war, bevor das Fake News das große Thema war, spielt ihr auch so ein bisschen mit rein. Äh da müsste man einfach nochmal vielleicht den etablierten Medien auch noch deutlicher sagen
dass man nicht immer, dass sie einfach nicht immer nur alles quantitativ messen dürfen und dann sagen folgende Nachricht wurde irgendwie so und so oft geteilt oder das Internet denkt so und so, weil's eben eine bestimmte quantitative
Nachweisbarkeit dafür gibt, weil wenn das nicht sozusagen qualitativ unterfüttert ist, ist das diese Aussage wertlos, weil's eben Bots sein können. Und ich.
Also Hashtag Trending und so weiter. Das das äh das finde ich gut, dass du das sagst, dieses diese quantitative
Sichtweise, ja, die sich nur von Zahlen äh belegen lässt. Hat so und so viel Likes und so, sagt halt, das sagt halt wirklich gar nichts aus. Und im Prinzip glaube ich
ist das jetzt auch der richtige Zeitpunkt, wo man dieses Facting nicht nur hochlobt,
sondern vielleicht auch einfach mal als solches thematisiert, weil äh,
Vermutlich ist es jetzt erforderlich, dass dieser äh dieser Prozess, der der Quellenüberprüfung
für den äh der etablierte Journalismus, von dem er immer so begeistert ist und so gerne dafür äh steht und so, was ja auch absolut richtig ist. Aber das ist jetzt sozusagen, das muss jetzt ein Volkssport werden,
und hier muss äh müssen diese Methoden, glaube ich, jetzt auch jedermann vermittelt werden, weil einfach jetzt jedermann auch Teil der Medien äh Verläufe ist.
Genau, aber ich glaube echt, also klar, jeder Mensch sollte sich das überlegen oder das das stärker zu eigen machen
aber ich glaube echt bei den klassischen Medien brauchst du oder bei den etablierten Medien, brauchst da schon echten Wandel, weil also ich meine, es ist ja auch so einfach, äh wenn du mal eben schnell eine Meldung schreiben kannst, irgendwie raushauen kannst und sagen kannst, ah ich hab's hier, habe hier eine klare Zahl ähm und das Internet denkt so und so, das Netz äh findet das und das.
Machen wir nochmal eine ganz klassische Forderung. Das müsste ein Fach in der Schule werden.
Ja und ehrlich gesagt, also es hat auch damit zu tun, wie die Journalisten oder Medien dann arbeiten, die die Etablierten
Weiß ich nicht, da muss es halt große gibt's ja teilweise schon Abteilungen und im Zweifelsfall halt weniger Druck jetzt schnell Klicks generieren, schnell Nachrichten schreiben, sondern eben äh Redakteuren so viel Zeit geben. Ähm Sachen gut zu recherchieren, dass sie es auch überprüfen können.
Kriegst du natürlich trotzdem das Problem nicht mit hin, dass äh dass jemand einfach irgendwelchen Schluss in Facebook schreibt.
Genau, ist wie gesagt, ist ein anderer Bereich, hängt irgendwie ein bisschen zusammen, genau. Aber Facebook ist vielleicht ein gutes Stichwort, oder?
Genau, Facebook ist ein gutes Stichwort, denn Facebook hat eine äh hat angekündigt, sich des Themas anzunehmen. Zunächst in den USA äh wollen sie einige ähm Änderungen,
ausrollen und testen bevor sie die dann irgendwann der gesamten Welt äh zugänglich machen. Das ist eigentlich ähm.
Also,
Wenn man sich überlegt, dass einmal im Raum stand man verbietet hier jetzt die Unwahrheit, was irgendwie das das Ministery of True am Ende geworden wäre, was sicherlich am Ende eine eher schlechte Idee gewesen wäre.
Oder man zensiert diese Dinger vollständig weg, was am Ende nur Wasser auf den Mühlen der Verschwörungstheoretiker gewesen wäre, hat Facebook sich jetzt dazu
äh entschieden vier Maßnahmen zu kombinieren. Erstens, sie sagen, man kann jetzt als Nutzer.
Falschmeldungen oder den Verdacht auf eine Falschmeldung ähm quasi klicken. Das ist notwendig natürlich, um irgendwie diese diesen,
deren Algorithmen Dinge lernen zu lassen, ja? Das heißt, sie brauchen ja immer erstmal einen Menschen, der ihre Algorithmen schult und das kann man also jetzt machen. Man kann, man hat jetzt einen Flag. Das äh ist offenbar nicht wahr.
Ja, aber Crowdsourcing hängt natürlich immer noch sehr von der Crowd ab und äh die ist ja das Problem.
Das ist anfällig für ähm für äh gezielte Nichtbeachtung oder gezielte Nutzung dieses Flakes. Na.
Genau, da kommt dann halt also wirklich ein gut belegter Artikel raus und dann kommt dann irgendwie so die rechte Gamerglatte.
Tagesschau, Lügenpresse.
Genau und dann wird das einfach weggeklickt und deswegen äh versuchen sie ja jetzt sich sozusagen auch mit Organisationen zusammenzutun.
Genau, ja Moment, also was passiert, wenn ich da drauf klicke? Erstmal, was passiert, wenn ich da draufklicke? Dann geht eine Meldung an Facebook und und eine Meldung an dem Postverfasser,
Das sind die beiden die beiden Dinge die dann passieren, ne? Also Facebook geht dann der Sache nach, wenn sich genug Leute darüber beschwert haben und der Postverfasser wird, wenn sich genug Leute darüber beschwert haben.
Weißt du an der Postverfassung auch schon sofort, wer sich da äh beschwert hat, also kriegen die Nazis sozusagen von den linken Factcheckern dann auch sofort die Adressen übermittelt.
Da gehe ich nicht von aus.
Die die gemeldeten Posts gehen dann an Factchecking äh
Organisationen äh in diesem Falle in den USA wird erstmal an das Pointer-Institut, dass sie dann nach den Leitlinien des internationalen Factchecking Networks prüft,
ja? Interessant, dass Facebook da wieder die Drecksarbeit aus äh Outsource. Ähm aber das nur am Rande.
Und wenn das dann passiert ist, dann dann wird diese Meldung ähm,
als umstritten gepflegt. Ja also ich glaube ich ich glaube schon, wenn sich genug Leute darüber beschwert haben. Also dann dann,
wird quasi dieser Bereich kriegt dann diese Meldung, kriegt dann einen, so einen Rand oder was? Und da steht dann Disputible oder so, also das ist hier umstritten, was hier gerade berichtet wird.
Und das hat zur Folge, wenn man diese Nachricht dann postet oder diesen Post
schert oder was auch immer, dass man doppelt bestätigen muss. Dann wird nämlich Facebook sagen, du, du äh kurz mal hier,
Bist du sicher, dass du das weiter verbreiten möchtest? Wir haben irgendwie einen guten Hinweis, dass es sich hierbei um Stuss handelt. Und da musst du also quasi zweimal klicken, was äh denke ich auch eine erzieherische,
Maßnahme ist davor zu warnen. Gleichzeitig aber natürlich es nicht zu verhindern. Du musst halt nur zweimal klicken.
Und das Ganze wird dann abgerennt, abgerundet mit Algorithmusänderungen, äh die Face,
die Fake News herabstufen, sodass sie seltener geteilt werden. Das ist ganz witzig, weil ich meine, wie oft die geteilt werden, ist ja
eine Sache, wir sehen das ja auch bei der Lokbuchnetzpolitik, Facebook-Seite. Ähm das ganze Light Lood Share, wie du willst, dass Facebook sortiert das dann eben am Ende wieder aus und da werden sie also eine Benachteiligung
im Algorithmus herbeiführen für diese äh für Nachrichten, bei denen sie hinreichend davon ausgehen, dass es sich um Fake-Nachrichten handelt.
Zunächst einmal denke ich ist zu loben, dass es da eben keine, dass das keine Zensurmaßnahme ist.
Das kann man doch mal positiv hervorheben.
Also es gibt bestimmt Leute, die das auch anders empfinden, würde ich mal vermuten, ne? Also äh aber ist erstmal jetzt kein, es wird nichts gelöscht, wenn ich's richtig verstanden habe, ne.
Weil.
Also Facebook sagt jetzt nicht, äh hier Upload-Filter äh.
Das darf man nicht mehr teilen oder so, dass man.
Sie werden aber sie benachteiligen halt so etwas. Das heißt sie wollen diesen diesen Durchlauferhitzer äh der Filterblase so ein bisschen da dem entgegenwirken.
Ja, ich finde es auch erstmal gut, dass sie was machen, aber es ist natürlich, man es ist schon echt eine krasse Macht
das muss man sich an der Stelle bewusst werden, die die Plattform an der Stelle hat. Äh das hat man irgendwie gibt's immer wieder Berichte, wenn Facebook eine Kleinigkeit an diesem Algorithmus ändert. Äh da was das für den Traffic von Seiten äh bedeutet, ne? Also die können ganz, ganz äh einfach bestimmte Seiten kaltstellen.
Das heißt jetzt nicht, äh dass das auf jeden Fall falsch sein muss. Ähm aber ja, weiß ich nicht, man muss jetzt ist es halt extrem sensibel, finde ich.
Und das muss, wenn, deshalb ist es gut, dass sie es jetzt irgendwie testen äh und nicht jetzt irgendwie gleich ausrollen, äh würde ich mal sagen.
Also mir tut das ein bisschen weh, aber das äh äh ich glaube, das ist eine ganz gute Idee. Also eine bessere hätte ich nicht gehabt, das ist immer mein Gradmesser.
Ja, das ist, sagen wir mal, ich würde sagen, es ist auf jeden Fall wert, das Ganze mal auszuprobieren ähm inwiefern das eben auch resistent ist. Es ist natürlich in dem Moment schwierig, wo du eine Organisation reinholst.
Die jetzt so quasi die die Wahrheit bemisst, ja,
weil erstens ist dann auch diese Organisation natürlich ganz anderen ähm Drücken ausgesetzt, ja? Also was ist, wenn jetzt so eine etablierte Webseite unterwandert wird, das ist so das eine beziehungsweise was ist.
Bennon hat schon das Face Institut gegründe.
Genau, alternatives Facts vergegen. Ja genau. Die Altfact-Check.
Altfeld, gell? Ähm
dann ist natürlich noch zu sehen, es gibt also Facebook ist einfach zu, es sind zu viele Posts, die es da gibt, das ist zu kleinteilig. Gleichzeitig können große Lobbygruppen
mit Leichtigkeit so Sachen hinkriegen und dann wie's bei bei Netzwerk Ork, äh, Markus Reuter noch daraufhin,
Kommentare sind ohnehin streitbar, ne? Also Meinungsäußerungen sind immer Disputible. Wir werden mal sehen, was was damit passiert, ne.
Genau. Ja oder auch Thema. Also ist wenn man so an Thema Klimawandel denkt oder so, ähm der stelle ich mir das mit dem Flagging zum Beispiel auch hochgrade interessant vor.
Ja, das muss man jetzt sehen, welche neue Wahrheit äh Trump äh formuliert, ne. Es gab ja erste Berichte, dass er eine Blacklist mit Wissenschaftlern anlegen möchte, die irgendwie über Klimawandel berichten, weil das ihm nicht passt.
Ich habe noch gefunden vielleicht, wenn noch zu ergänzen oder wolltest du,
Ähm bei Twitter, es gibt ja diese ähm US Soziologen, die auch für die Times schreibt, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man sie ausspricht. Glaube ich. Ähm die echt
kluge Sachen zu dem Thema immer wieder schreibt, zur öffentlichen Verantwortung von von der Plattform Facebook, finde ich und die hat nochmal ein paar Punkte ergänzt, die eigentlich notwendig wären, ähm weil das Problem ähm äh der,
sozusagen der Fake News jetzt nicht alles ist
bei Facebook, sondern es irgendwie die immer diskutierten Echokammern ähm ja gibt quasi, dass die Leute sich nur noch das teilen, was sie ohnehin schon denken und das müssen äh nicht mal nur die äh krassen äh Fakemeldungen sein, wie dass der Papst jetzt irgendwie sich für Donald Trump entscheidet
sodass die irgendwie tatsächlich eindeutig jetzt irgendwie rausfliegen würden und die sagt halt, dass es eben extrem wichtig wäre,
einfach mehr Vielfalt Diversity in die Echokammern in die Feeds der Leute zu bringen. Zum Beispiel indem es eine die gibt's glaube ich in.
Weiß ich gar nicht, ob sie in Deutschland gibt bei Facebook so eine related Content-Box, wo einfach zu bestimmten Themen Sachen drinstehen, die vielleicht explizit äh eine andere Perspektive darauf geben. Ähm.
Auf als als das, was ich sonst immer so in meinem Feed habe, ja? Also ich glaube, die gibt's aber in Deutschland gar nicht, related Content-Box, Aldono.
Habe ich noch nicht gesehen, aber ich benutze das ja auch nicht, dieses äh heißt das jetzt Faktbook.
Fakebook zu von Facebook, zu Facebook.
Wäre mal was oder Fake oder Fakebook. Facebook oder Facebook, das ist hier die Frage.
Was man halt auf jeden Fall, da weiß ich auch drauf hin, wichtig wäre eigentlich äh.
Dass die Forschung, die dazu gemacht wird und das Ausprobieren, dass Facebook das eigentlich nicht nur für sich alleine macht, sondern dass sie sich auch unabhängige Wissenschaftler dazu holen, äh ja, um eben klarzumachen, äh um eine gewisse Verantwortung ähm.
Wahrzunehmen, ja, an der Stelle.
Ja, ich glaube, der Zuckermann den Beat ist jetzt auch ein bisschen der Arsch aufgrund, als jetzt hat er irgendwie schon den Amerikanern, den Trump mit diesem Teel irgendwie so indirekt eingebrockt und dann noch die Nummer, also.
Ja und äh ich glaube ehrlich gesagt, dem ist das egal, aber.
Ja, mal schauen.
Weit würde ich nicht gehen. Ich halte.
Zwar für den irgendwie streitbarsten aller äh Zero ist da in diesem ganzen Digital Bubble äh soweit will ich jetzt auch noch nicht gehen.
Ähm.
Wäre interessant zu wissen, was sie bei dem Gespräch gestern besprochen haben.
Ja, da werden wir glaube ich alle gerne Mäuschen gewesen, aber.
Ja, da müsstest du da halt dein Kind von Donald Trump sein, dann darfst du auch am Tisch sitzen.
Ich kann mir auf jeden Fall vorstellen, wer am wenigsten gesagt hat.
Ähm habt ihr das mitbekommen, dass also wir das Gespräch, auf das wir gerade ansprechen, ist das Donald Trump die ganzen Silicon Valley Giganten zu sich an den Tisch gestellt hat und dann gab's ein Meeting. Ähm
Wo dann auch drei von Donald Trumps Kindern mit an äh am Tisch saßen, damit er keine Interessenkonflikte finanzieller Natur hat, weil.
Und ähm und einer war nicht mit an Bord von den von dem großen von äh von Silicon Valley. Offizielle Begründung mit dreizehn Milliarden oder sowas, oder? Eins Komma drei Milliarden Bewertungen wäre Twitter eben kein Gigant. Twitter war nicht teuer genug
Inoffizielle Begründung Twitter hatte nicht auf Donald Trumps Wunsch ein Emoji für Cruced Hillery eingeführt
Und zwar macht äh macht Twitter das wohl, du kannst dir quasi zu einem Hashtag kaufen, dass das durch einen durch einen Emoji, durch ein spezifisches Limboji, das auch nicht im UTF acht Standard liegen muss.
Also technisch handelt es sich hier eher um einen Sticker, ist es nur so, dass Twitter das brandet Emojis nennt.
Ach so, okay, also das das Hashtag wird ersetzt durch ein kleines Bild. Sticker, keine Eiwei.
Ja, ja. Man nennt das Sticker, was.
Okay, Vanetta Sticker. So, da gibt's dann halt ein ein kleines äh ein kleines Sticker, äh der das Hashtag ersetzt und äh das Emborgy, was der Trump Social Media Experte haben wollte, war ein ein Hunty, ein Dollarsack entgegennimmt
Oh, gut, Hillary Clitten zu symbolisieren und ähm das ist irgendwie mit Twitter nicht zustande gekommen und es man munkelt also hinter den hinter verschlossener Tür, dass äh Trump
das als Anlass genommen hat, Twitter nicht zu dieser Runde einzuladen. Also allein die Idee
dieses Emoje, diese Sticker zu machen und dann auch noch jemanden deshalb nicht einzuladen zeigt wieder mit welcher mit welcher Weitsicht und Großmütigkeit dieser äh Präsident gesegnet ist.
Er will ein Präsident für alle sein, also für alle Arschlöcher auf jeden Fall.
Gut, dann letzte letztes, ganz kurz zum Thema Wahlmanipulation und Hacking. Angestoßen wurde das Ganze ja dadurch, dass die, dass das CIA sagt, ähm diese Wahl wurde von.
Der im Rossen manipuliert, denn der Russe hat ähm so, dass hier A nicht die CIA, nicht nur,
Die Demokraten gehackt, sondern auch die Republikaner und die äh die bei den Republikaner erbeuteten, die bei den Republikanern erbeuteten Daten seien, aber nicht geliegt worden und deswegen sei das hier eine.
Eine Einflussnahme des ähm der des russischen Geheimdiensts auf den Ausgang der Wahl gewesen.
Trumps Reaktion darf man da nicht vorenthalten, die war nämlich tatsächlich durchaus gewitzt. Der sagt dann einfach, ey, das sind die gleichen Leute, die gesagt haben, Saddam Hussein hätte Massenvernichtungswaffen, wollt ihr denen etwa noch glauben,
und damit war dieses Thema dann auch vom Tisch.
Was natürlich auch nicht stimmt, weil es war ja nicht das CIA, der sich dazu geäußert hat, sondern es war ja die Regierung selber.
Das interessiert doch kein.
Das interessiert wirklich alles überhaupt gar keinen mehr. Es ist einfach äh ist vollkommen egal. Warum? Warum erzählen wir eigentlich hier noch die ganze Zeit die Wahrheit? Das das schlägt doch einfach überhaupt nicht durch. Wenn wir jetzt einfach.
Ist lächerlich, hä? Die Hörerzahlen stagnieren.
Ja, eigentlich genau. Wir hauen jetzt einfach mal äh ein paar falsche Zitate raus, ja, regen uns ordentlich darüber auf, was wieder irgendjemand falsches, furchtbares gesagt hat, ja, dass sie alle irgendwie ja, der Kinderpornoring und in den in den Katakomben des Reichstags.
Das sind doch die Sachen, die die Leute interessieren, ja.
Ähm
Weil wir uns ja immer noch in die, weil wir ja irgendwie hinterherschleifen und immer noch im im Zeitalter der Fakten uns bewegen wollen, empfehlen wir an dieser Stelle nochmal den Vortrag von Alex Haldermann
Presidential Election an Tag zwei, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, der ist dreiunddreißig C drei
mit ach und Krach auch noch in Saal. Eins positioniert vierzehn Uhr dreißig Tag zwei.
Das war übrigens hier Schleichwerbung, ne? Da sieht man mal, dass dass ich auch hier überhaupt nicht Business und äh.
Weil du ja auch Aktien hast, ne.
Der Aktien in der Veranstaltung.
Aber besser als Fake News.
Besser als Fake News. So, jetzt der Linkverbot, wir dürfen nicht mehr Linken, Tim.
Ne, Linken ist verboten, das hat ja schon der europäische äh Gerichtshof vor einiger Zeit ähm festgestellt, dass das äh gar nicht geht
Wir haben uns ja hier von Zeit zu Zeit auch über das ein oder andere Entscheidung des Europäischen Gerichtshofs ähm gefreut
ja dort auch einige paar grundsätzliche Feststellungen zu äh für uns so wichtige Themen wie Vorratsdatenspeicherung et cetera ähm.
Zustande gekommen sind, die äh durchaus die Debatte äh auf eine interessante Art und Weise angereichert haben, sollten wir noch so ein bisschen das Gefühl bekommen hat, dass sie schon das ein oder andere verstanden haben.
Gab's halt dieses Urteil ähm vom achten September. Das hatten wir hier, glaube ich, auch äh seiner Zeit äh erwähnt, dass im Prinzip sagt,
auch das Setzen eines Links eine Urheberrechtsverletzung sein kann. Denn wenn diese verlinkte Webseite wiederum dann urheberrechtlich geschütztes Werk,
ohne Einwilligung des Urhebers veröffentlicht, dann trägt man da sozusagen so eine Mitschuld. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das hier noch groß
äh wert ist, diese Sichtweise hier nochmal aufzurollen, weil ich glaube jeder, der so halbwegs äh schon mal mit dem Internet eine halbe Stunde gearbeitet hat, versteht einfach, was das für eine für einen warnwitzige Feststellung ist, ja,
und ähm da kann man natürlich jetzt äh versuchen alle möglichen Reword-Vergleiche äh zu zu bringen. Warum das irgendwie nicht geht, aber äh ich finde, das ist sogar schon aus der Technik heraus ähm.
Ist das sozusagen vermittelbar? Weil ein Link ist sozusagen man man verlässt ja sozusagen den eigenen Geltungsbereich
also wenn man jetzt nicht auf sich selber linkt und ähm
Zeit lang ist jetzt auch glaube ich nicht mehr so auf dem Wog, ne? Hat man ja dann auch mal doch, ich glaube bei YouTube ist das auch immer noch, du klickst auf so einen Link und dann kommt dann erstmal so eine Seite, dazwischen, die Facebook hat das glaube ich auch so. Sie verlassen jetzt hier irgendwie sozusagen unseren Bereich, sind sie sich sicher, dass sie sozusagen das Internet verlassen wollen,
äh ja ähm
könnte man sogar fast noch überlegen, ob man sowas sozusagen als Rettung macht, das so an jedem Link nochmal so ein, so, so ein, so ein Panik, ja, was krippt
Kot dransteckt, der sagt so, oh ja, nee, jetzt ist hier also wirklich der Deutungsbereich und das ist ja eigentlich gar nicht wirklich ein Link. Und wenn sie jetzt diesem Link folgenden auf eigene Fahrt, was natürlich totaler Humbug ist.
Genau, auf diesen Link klicken auf eigene Gefahr.
Jetzt war das zunächst einmal nur eine Entscheidung des europäischen Gerichtshof Pess,
und man dachte sich so na ja, schauen wir mal. Jetzt gab's aber dann wiederum eine weitere Entscheidung auf Basis eines Falls in Deutschland und dort kam das für seine,
ich sag mal.
Schwierige Handhabung des Themas Urheberrechts bekannte Landgericht in Hamburg äh ins Spiel, die halt in einem Fall, den ich jetzt gerade ehrlich gesagt nicht so im Detail
nacherzählen kann, ähm, gesagt hat, na ja, also wie der OEGH schon festgestellt hat, äh, ist das ja jetzt so und jetzt entscheiden wir in diesem Fall halt auch mal so, sprich es wurde jemand in Haftung genommen dafür, dass äh er auf etwas verlinkt hat. Und nun ist es natürlich ein bisschen abenteuerlich
ein Link,
Ich meine, es wird ja noch nicht mal der Zeitpunkt der Verlinkung in irgendeiner Form berücksichtigt, ne? Ich meine, ich sage, ja, da hinten ist alles in Ordnung und zehn Minuten später ist nicht mehr alles in Ordnung. Ich meine, man kann ja nicht,
Alle seine Links, meine hab
ein Block voll mit zehn Jahre äh äh links. Was weiß ich, ob da noch dieselben Domains dahinter sind, ob da noch dieselben Betreiber sind, ob die noch dieselbe Einstellung zur freiheitlichen äh Grundordnung haben. Hu Norse und äh so,
ja
Also ich kann immer kurz erzählen, ähm worum's in dem Fall ging, also
wirklich des Urteils in Hamburg äh des des Hamburger Landgerichts. Äh zeigt erst richtig, wie absurd die Entscheidung ähm des EuGH zu dem Thema war. Es geht darum, dass hier ein eine Beklagte Einheit äh,
ein auf ein Bild verlinkt hat, äh das bei Wikipedia eingestellt war unter Kommenslizenz und das Bil.
Äh die Lizenz verletzt, weil da nämlich jemand in eine Landschaft Ufos reingebaut hatte, ohne darauf hinzuweisen, hat also ein Ursprungsbild genommen und das verändert aber nicht angezeigt
also da gegen die Bedingungen der CC-Lizenzen verstoßen, weil es eben nicht angezeigt wurde und darauf hat dann äh eine Person beziehungsweise ein Blog äh glaube ich war es verlinkt.
Und es wird jetzt in Mithaftung für diese Urheberrechtsverletzung, die ursprünglich Urheberrechtsverletzungen genommen. Ähm und.
Also es war auch noch eine C-Lizenz. Das ist okay, das Detail war mir noch gar nicht klar.
Und es geht um ein Bild in das Ufos reingebaut wurden ähm und ja der EuGH das Landgericht Hamburg ähm macht da irgendwie jetzt
besonderen Hinweis auf den kommerziellen ähm Charakter quasi ähm und sagt Unwissenheit, also das gilt besonders oder gilt jetzt im im Prinzip, ähm wenn's
irgendwo im kommerziellen Bereich stattfindet. Ähm das würde aber zum Beispiel, wenn ich mir jetzt Netzpolitik angucke, zum Beispiel Netzwerky Punkt org, schaltet auch extrem selten, zwar aber manchmal ähm irgendwie eine kleine Werbung irgendwie ähm,
und das heißt auch Netzpolitik Punkt org äh wäre jetzt ein kommerzielles Produkt demnach, ähm das heißt auch wir müssten jetzt quasi jeden Link prüfen, denn das Gericht sagt explizit
Unwissenheitsschützer vor Strafe nicht, äh, man muss ja, man muss eigentlich sich dann besonders.
Informieren dazu und sich ja und das nachprüfen, ähm ob,
da wo man hin verlinkt, wirklich alles in Ordnung ist mit dem Urheberrecht. Also hochgradig absurd.
Ja, heiße Online hat sich da auch äh besonders äh drüber aufgeregt, also einerseits äh drüber berichtet, aber natürlich sehen die sich
wie so viele andere auch äh dort extrem bedroht, weil natürlich jetzt alles, worauf sie verlinken und dann Heise hat er in den letzten Jahren schon einige Fälle, äh wo das auch mal ein Thema war.
Und äh kam dann auf die äh pfiffige Idee, doch einfach, äh da sie ja unter anderem auch auf das Landgericht in Hamburg verlinken
Ähm doch auch hier mal sicherzustellen, dass sozusagen alles in Ordnung ist, weil diese Rechtssprechung sagt ja jetzt im Prinzip du musst dich von jedem Link sozusagen davon,
muss sicherstellen, dass
irgendwo auf der ganzen Seite oder zumindest auf dem kompletten Webserver, was weiß ich, ob das da irgendwo noch gilt, wenn man irgendwie weiter klickt. Äh sozusagen, ob da alles in Ordnung ist und das wollten sie sich einfach mal bestätigen lassen und schrieben halt so unter anderem an das Landgericht,
darf sie daher bitten uns schriftlich verbindlich zu bestätigen, dass sämtliche der im Rahmen ihrer Webpräsenz verwendeten urheberrechtlich geschützten Inhalte in keiner Form und an keiner Stelle gegen die Vorgaben des Urheberrechts
oder Verwandtergesetze verstoßen. Wir wären ihnen dankbar, wenn sie uns diese verbindliche Erklärung schriftlich zukommen lassen
Dies gilt insbesondere für das äh Angebot unter URL, äh sowie sämtliche Unterseiten.
Bitte haben Sie Verständnis dafür, dass wir diese Erklärung für die Zeit kritische Berichterstattung sehr zeitnah benötigen? Daher muss uns diese verbindliche Erklärung spätestens morgen, Freitag, zwölf Uhr vorlegen.
Und sie haben sie nicht abgegeben. Das Gericht hat gesagt, sie macht es, sie können es nicht garantieren, ne?
Ähm genau, also sie wollte es zumindest nicht äh rechtsverbindlich tun, also sie haben dann tatsächlich äh geantwortet und ähm meint so, nee, ist schon alles okay bei uns,
Ich meine, es wäre auch noch geiler. Wenn du's erst auf Urheberrecht spezialisiert.
Folgenden Unterseiten finden sie Urüberrechtsverletzungen.
Ja, will das aber nicht rechtsverbindlich zusichern und ich meine, wenn schon ein Gericht, was spezialisiert ist für Ulübericht, nicht rechtlich verbindlich zusichern kann. Äh wer soll denn das dann bitte sonst tun.
Ja, also das ist schon nochmal äh Füllstoff für eine ganze Menge äh an interessanten Folge von Folgedebatten und äh wir haben's hiermit, glaube ich, mit einer Absurdität zu tun, wo ich jetzt fast schon immer wieder ganz mutig sagen würde.
Das kann nicht so bleiben.
Nee, ich kann also die Konsequenz würde ja sein, wir hören auf, Links zu setzen eigentlich, weil keiner kann das immer nachprüfen, so und das ist muss man nur einen Schritt weiter denken, dann dann weiß nicht, ist eins der Grundprinzipien des Internets.
Ja, aber dann gibt's auch keine Fake News mehr.
Vielleicht könnte man einfach.
Immer, es gibt ja noch keine News mehr, aber.
Vielleicht könnte man einfach den Stecker insgesamt mal ziehen.
Genau, einfach links abschaffen ähm die Nuss oder? Ist eh doof oder mit den Links. Macht nur Arbeit. Schafft nur äh Rechtsunsicherheit auch.
Ja auch echt irgendwie, ne, das ist irgendwie so so ein siebziger Jahre Ding, ne.
Halber Textvisionen aus der Vergangenheit. Ah liegende, liegende Autos und so.
Nun Delbon. Und dann war ja noch was. Es gibt da eine neue Initiative.
Die sogenannte E-Privacy äh Richtlinie und,
Ist auch so ein bisschen der Grund gewesen immer warum wir dich äh heute eingeladen haben, weil im Gegensatz zu uns hast du dich da schon etwas intensiver mit auseinandergesetzt,
Ähm uns äh flugs nur so ein bisschen auf den Tisch. Äh so mit dem mit der Anmerkung ist wichtig,
Von daher würden wir gerne von dir mal wissen äh was ist das jetzt hier eigentlich, wer äh heckt da gerade was aus und warum ist das so wichtig.
Genau, ja, ich freue mich sehr, dass ihr mich eingeladen habt sowieso, aber vor allen Dingen auch, weil ihr dieses Thema aufgenommen habt, ist noch relativ früh ähm in in einem politischen Prozess ähm und wir haben eben bei Netzpolitik Ex
Sie zieht mal versucht, jetzt irgendwie nicht erst, wenn das Thema durch ist oder wenn's auf dem Tisch ist, sondern das im Vorfeld schon mal so ein bisschen zu beleuchten. Ähm
Und das ist jetzt gerade akut geworden, weil äh da ein Dokument ähm aus der Kommission EU-Kommission gelegt worden ist. Also worum geht's? Grundsätzlich ähm Richtlinie ist äh ein EU äh,
Gesetz im weiteren Sinne ja, dass es seit zweitausendzwei,
gibt schon, ähm, die existiert schon die E-Privace, die Richtlinie ähm und die quasi nochmal explizite Regeln ähm für den Datenschutz und die Vertraulichkeit im Bereich der elektronischen Kommunikation vorgibt. Also es gibt ja oft,
EU-Ebene schon seit neunzehnhundertfünfundneunzig eine Datenschutzrichtlinie und als Ergänzung für den Bereich der elektronischen Kommunikation hat man nochmal spezifische Regeln erlassen zweitausendzwei und dann im Nachgang nochmal ein bisschen überarbeitet. Ähm.
Wie ist das, wie ist das Verhältnis.
Warte mal, wir müssen vielleicht nochmal eins noch erwähnen, also Richtlinie, wir sagen das immer alles so äh mit so einer Selbstverständlichkeit. Wir reden natürlich jetzt hier von einer Maßnahme der Europäischen Union,
der Kommission
und auch nochmal für die Leute, die den Unterschied nicht kennen. Es gibt da Richtlinien und es gibt da Verordnungen, Verordnungen sind Dinge, die greifen unmittelbar sofort in allen Ländern, sind unmittelbar rechtsverbindlich wie zum Beispiel jetzt bei der Datenschutzgrundverordnung, über die wir hier viel gesprochen haben. Richtlinien sind sozusagen
Empfehlungen oder Leitlinien für eine zukünftige Gesetzgebung, die dann halt national auch noch ins Gesetz umgesetzt werden muss, was manchmal passiert und.
Genau, teilweise auch nicht.
Aber das ist jetzt genauso, so haben sich wahrscheinlich die hörenden gefühlt die bei der bei der äh Telekom Roter Sache nicht mehr mitgekommen sind, so wie ich mich jetzt fühle. Also.
Verordnung.
Nein, wie wie ist das Verhältnis von EU-Datenschutzreform? Zu E-Privacy Richtlinie.
Das hängt quasi zusammen. Also äh in den letzten Jahren äh ist ja eines der großen Themen gewesen, die ja, die EU-Datenschutz
Reform oder die Einführung einer Datenschutzgrundverordnung für Europa, die ab zweitausendachtzehn gilt, die ist Anfang dieses Jahres äh beschlossen worden und äh gilt oder wird dann wirksam, es anzuwenden ab Mai zweitausendachtzehn und.
Die E-Privacy Regeln ähm sind quasi nochmal eine spezifische Ergänzung. Datenschutz ist ja nicht nur äh,
gibt's ja nicht nur ist ja nicht nur relevant im Bereich äh von Internet, sage ich jetzt mal oder äh von,
Ja, von Kommunikationsdiensten, sondern auch noch in anderen Bereichen, aber ähm.
Aus gutem Grund gibt's quasi äh dann spezifische Regeln nochmal für den Bereich der elektronischen Kommunikation. Und bislang das ist jetzt eben eine der zentralen Punkte. Galt
galten diese Regeln aber nur für klassische Telekommunikationsdienste, das heißt ähm ja, ein Telefon und SMS im weitesten Sinne
waren da im Fokus. Ähm und.
Wie wenn man's mal ganz grundsätzlich beschreiben will, ist der Gedanke gewesen, wir übersetzen das Fernmeldegeheimnis in ähm in in,
das Zeitalter in die in das digitale Zeitalter und da steht jetzt zum Beispiel und steht dann auch jetzt schon eben drinne. Grundsätzlich es darf äh es darf keine Überwachung geben, äh Kommunikation darf nicht abgefangen, mitgehört werden und so weiter. Ähm das ist eine Grund
da stehen solche Sachen drinnen wie das.
Dass du das Recht hast, äh, auf Rufnummern, Unterdrückung oder dass du das Recht hast, auch eine Telefonrechnung zu bekommen, in der keine Einzel äh Nachweise drinstehen ähm,
Falls du dir zum Beispiel mit irgendeiner ist ja auch egal für welchen Fall, das steht da jedenfalls drinnen bislang die Regeln und es gibt auch, die wird teilweise Cookie-Richtlinie genannt, steht eben auch drinne, eigentlich, dass ähm,
Cookies,
Tracking Cookies grundsätzlich ähm nicht erlaubt sind, beziehungsweise der Einsatz von Tracking Cookies, die Einwilligung der Nutzer ähm.
Oder der betroffenen äh Leute,
darf, deshalb gibt's seit so ein paar Jahren ja immer diese Infoboxen, Cookie-Infoboxen, die man dann einfach nur weglegt. Weil die Regeln eben nicht so richtig umgesetzt wurden. Äh zumindest in Deutschland nicht. Ähm es heißt zwar eigentlich, du sollst freiwillig zustimmen müssen,
oder dürfen dazu, aber du hast ja in Deutschland zum Beispiel keine Wahl, du, die meisten Webseiten, auf die du gehst, da kannst du sagen, ja ich stimme dem zu, dass es hier Tracking Surt Party Tracking Cookies gibt oder ich gehe halt weg, gehe nicht auf die Seite.
Dass es das ist genau dieser äh Richtlinie geschuldet.
Das ist der Umsetzung dieser Richtlinie geschulde
und äh auch der letztendlich der Durchsetzung, also in Frankreich zum Beispiel wird das ganz anders umgesetzt, da ist die Datenschutzaufsicht äh stärker dahinterher, die kontrollieren das regelmäßig und verhängen dann im Zweifelsfall auch mal Strafen. Das heißt, in Frankreich ist es jetzt anders als in Deutschland, da hast du dann echt auch die Möglichkeit, auf vielen Webseiten
die zu besuchen, ohne dass irgendwie Tracking Cookies eingesetzt werden. Wenn du dem eben nicht zustimmst.
Ähm genau und das ist jetzt aber, jetzt gibt es ein Update quasi, ja? Ähm weil eine der großen Schwächen,
oder ein, einer der großen Mängel der bisherigen Richtlinie eben ist
Sie bezieht sich nur auf klassische Telekommunikation, Internet und Telefonie in weiten Teilen, aber Messenger, äh, Apps, Internettelefonie, äh, Direktnachrichten in Social Media, ähm,
und so weiter, Webmail spielen ja auch eine große Rolle für die Kommunikation und deshalb ist jetzt einer der eines der Anliegen gewesen, ähm den die Reichweite quasi dieser Richtlinie zu erhöhen,
beziehungsweise um auch kurz auf den Prozess zu gucken, bevor ich sage, was jetzt neu drinsteht.
Die Kommission hat im Sommer eine Konsultation gemacht, hat also eine große Umfrage gemacht ähm oder die Möglichkeit gegeben, daran teilzunehmen und irgendwie seine Meinung dazu zu sagen. Sollten die Regeln besser geschützt, sollten wir besser geschützt werden oder nicht. Ähm.
Genau. Und,
Jetzt ist eben, dass es, äh, warum ihr mich eingeladen habt, ist der aktuelle Anlass, es ist äh ein erster Entwurf öffentlich geworden, den die Kommission äh vorschlägt,
oder in abgewandelter Form dann vorschlagen wird für über eine Überarbeitung.
Öffentlich geworden in dem Fall unfreiwillig, oder?
Ich man weiß das ja nie, äh wer mit welchen Intentionen Sachen liegt, äh ist es jedenfalls bei, also nicht die Kommission hat's offiziell veröffentlicht, sondern ist bei Politico äh ein Scan ähm von einem Entwurf von Ende November
eingestellt ähm worden und.
Der ist ja interessant an vielen Stellen, ähm weil's echt so einige hochgradig strittige Fragen gibt und weil das Feld natürlich hochgradig Lobby behaftet ist ähm,
Da letztendlich geht's um.
Die Grundfragen, die uns irgendwie ziemlich viel beschäftigen, ja, wie steht's um Tracking, wie steht's um Profil, irgendwie steht's um Werbung? Äh wie steht's letztendlich um den Schutz unserer Privatsphäre und äh unserer Daten. Ähm.
Und äh äh Lobbybehaftet, du sagst das so, das ist wir erinnern uns glaube ich bei der EU-Datenschutzgrundreform, das war der größte Lobbyaufmaß, den,
den die EU da das Parlament gesehen hatte, das wird sich da wahrscheinlich ähnlich verhalten.
Zumindest ab jetzt schätze ich mal, äh, spätestens ab jetzt, also wobei, es gab ehrlich gesagt schon relativ.
Man weiß, dass es natürlich nicht so genau, was in Brüssel so alles vor sich geht, aber es gab schon, wann war das hier Ende? Es gab, es ist echt so geil, es gab.
Gemeinsames Statement am fünften Juli von zwölf großen Industrie und Handelsverbänden in Brüssel, die gesagt haben, die E-Privacy-Regel müssen komplett abgeschafft werden.
Wenn man sich mal anguckt, äh, wer da drin ist, dann weiß kriegt man ein Gefühl davon, ähm wie, wie, was für eine Bedeutung die Regeln haben. Es sind wirklich nämlich alle hier gewesen quasi. Google, Microsoft, Facebook, Apple, Amazon, Samsung, Blackberry, LG,
Huawei, IBM, Toshi über Philips, HPCSco, Intell deutsche Telekom und so weiter. T-Systems.
Orange, Telefonica kennen Fugifilms. Also wirklich, es ist ähm die haben alle gesagt, bitte die Regeln weg,
So und das ist jetzt mein gutes Zeichen dafür, dass dass die Regeln da bleiben sollten, finde ich. Ähm! Genau! Und spannend ist jetzt, was die EU-Kommission sich dazu denkt.
Ja. Genau, was steht denn jetzt drin?
Genau, vieles ähm und es ist nicht einfach, es ist jetzt nicht mit einer ganz einfachen Aussage dazu getan, ähm vielleicht mal so ganz grundsätzlich, äh wenn das so umgesetzt würde, wie die Kommission sich das vorstellt, das ist wie gesagt, wird jetzt noch,
ist alles noch vorläufig, ne? Ähm,
Dann wäre das erstmal schon mal ein guter Schritt äh für aus aus Verbrauchersicht, aus Nutzersicht, es ist auf jeden Fall schon so. Zum Beispiel,
sagen sie nämlich einerseits ganz grundsätzlich, es soll eine Verordnung werden, das heißt keine Richtlinie mehr, sondern eben echt verbindliche,
regeln, ne? Also was wir eben besprochen haben, Verordnung bedürfen eigentlich keine Umsetzungsgesetze mehr äh in den in den Mitgliedsstaaten, sondern gelten direkt. Ähm also verbindlichere Regeln. Dann,
Erweiterung der Reichweite, das heißt, diese Regeln gelten auch für
Messengerdienste Voiceover IP, Webmail und so weiter. Das dürfte vor allen Dingen zum Beispiel Google ärgern
weil die ja zum Beispiel bekanntermaßen alle Gmail, E-Mails analysieren quasi und da echt ähm dann in den Inhalt reingucken, automatisiert das wäre dann so nicht mehr erlaubt
beziehungsweise anders ist, wäre klar verboten, ähm ob's erlaubt ist jetzt gerade ähm ist ja eine umstrittene Frage.
Was bedeutet denn das jetzt ähm konkret? Also was was würde sich denn jetzt ändern, wenn diese E-Privacy-Linie in dieser Form oder in der ähnlichen Form dann äh tatsächlich durchgesetzt werden würde.
Also ein Punkt ist der interessantes ist, dass es bei dem Thema Meterdaten, also
Kommunikationsmeter, Daten, äh die ja hochgradig äh aussagekräftig sind über unsere Leben, ähm dass sich da erstmal keine großen Änderungen ergeben. Das ist einerseits kann man argumentieren gut,
weil die
weil's durchaus Bestrebungen gab zu sagen, ähm der Schutz von Meterdaten muss abgeschwächt werden, Unternehmen, wenn sie ein berechtigtes Interesse haben, sollen äh,
Kommunikationsmeterdaten verwenden und analysieren dürfen ähm dieses berechtigte Interesse, das ist jetzt erstmal.
Nicht reingeschrieben worden, das ist eine ganz gute Lösung, sondern es steht klar drinnen,
Die Verarbeitung vom Meterodaten ist nur erlaubt, wenn Nutzerinnen und Nutzer ihre Einwilligung geben.
Gleichzeitig hätte man sich natürlich auch wünschen können, dass es da ein klares Verbot gibt, kein Einwilligungsvorbehalt, unterschiedliche Organisationen hatten zum Beispiel gefordert, dass Tracking zum Beispiel komplett im Gesundheitsbereich verboten werden soll oder das Tracking von Minderjährigen soll komplett verboten werden. Das ist jetzt auch nicht drin, ne.
Ein zentraler Punkt.
Insgesamt im Datenschutz und beim Umgang mit unseren Daten ist ja das Thema Einwilligung, weil viele Sachen sind grundsätzlich verboten, außer ähm die die Firmen holen irgendwie unsere Einwilligung ein ähm und da,
sagt jetzt.
Die Kommission zumindest in diesem Vorschlag, dass wenn man ähm das, wenn man in seinem Browser zum Beispiel grundsätzlich signalisiert, ich bin gegen Tracking, ich möchte nicht getrackt werden, dass das tatsächlich auch.
Wirksamkeit hat, dass das gelten muss. Also.
Das ist das Tunort, dass du nur Track Feature wird jetzt in oder das die Duno Track Heada ist das ja glaube ich dann, der wird jetzt in Gesetz gegossen.
Genau,
In Kombination mit der Vorgabe, dass Privacy bei Design gilt, das heißt also Geräte und aber auch Softwarekomponenten wie zum Beispiel Browser müssen so voreingestellt sein, dass wenn sie ausgeliefert sind, wenn sie runtergeladen werden, dass sie dann erstmal
die Datenschutzfreundlichste Einstellung,
drin haben, das heißt, dass Donut Track quasi per Tieffold voreingestellt ist. Äh so, in in der Kombination diese beiden Sachen in Kombination könnten im Bereich Webtracking echt ähm,
guten Fortschritt äh bedeuten. Wenn du einerseits grundsätzlich signalisieren kannst durch eine Einstellung und deinen Browser, ich möchte nicht getrackt werden und das Verbindlichkeit hat und äh wenn andererseits,
Das eben voreingestellt ist, bislang sind die meisten Browser ja mit der Voreinstellung Cookies akzeptieren Flirt-Party, Cooks akzeptieren ist okay, Donutrack nicht an. Ähm das könnte tatsächlich ja echt,
was bringen.
Mit Einschränkungen, also ich äh bin jetzt schon mehrfach auch auf so Webseiten gestoßen. Sie ist halt irgendwie so ein Artikel, dann ist da so ein Video und dann kommt so der Hinweis, ja, du hast ja einen Track eingestellt, deswegen kann ich dir jetzt dieses Video nicht anzeigen, weil die ja nicht damit äh konform gehen
aber wenn du dann irgendwie auf ihre Webseite gehst, dann ist alles gut, ne?
Ja ähm ein anderer Punkt ist das Thema.
Da sind wir müssen wir echt mal ein bisschen gespannt sein, äh wie das denn in der Praxis äh äh umgesetzt wird oder wie der, wie das dann konkret sich auswirkt, ist eine Vorschrift für das Tracking anhand von äh.
Signalen, die dein Gerät sendet, wenn es sich mit Netzwerken oder einem anderen Gerät verbindet. Das heißt, wenn du irgendwie dich in WLAN einloggst oder so oder dein dein dein Smartphone nach WLAN sucht, sendet
ja immer Daten mit. Und das ist ja inzwischen relativ weit verbreitete Offline-Tracking-Methode quasi in in Shops zum Beispiel ähm
wird es inzwischen eingesetzt, dass anhand dass deine Bewegung in einem Laden zum Beispiel nachverfolgt werden.
Ja, müssen wir mal kurz äh also dass das ein tatsächlich ein sehr großes Tracking-Problem das Mobilfunk.
Geräte und auch Computer, um sich schneller mit WLANs
zu verbinden zu können, suchen die die ganze Zeit danach. Und das kannst du ähm sehr schön auslesen. Diese diese bietens, die das Telefon sendet und die sind natürlich,
sofort Unique für den einzelnen Nutzer. Das heißt beim, ne, der,
der fragt irgendwie nach seinem Heimnetzwerk, der fragt nach dem Netzwerk von zu Hause und die Kombination von Netzwerken, nach denen das Telefon sucht, ist im Prinzip mit mit an Sicherheitsgrenzen der Wahrscheinlichkeit einzigartig und atmet eignet sich daher für das Tracking und wenn du einfach nur eine WLAN-Antenne aufstellst und guckst
wer hier nach welchen Netzwerken fragt, dann kannst du darüber sehr schön ähm Nutzer,
zum Beispiel durch ein Einkaufszentrum und kannst sehen, wo gehen die eigentlich lang
wenn sie sich dann auch nochmal bei dir einloggen oder so und du sagst äh mach doch mal hier Facebook Login und like uns, dann weißt du relativ zügig äh um welche Person es sich handelt und kannst so
wirklich ein sehr interessantes äh Sensornetzwerk über die Welt verteilen. Und das kriegt man immer wieder mit, dass so öffentliche WLANs oder so genau das tun.
Genau und das soll erlaubt sein.
Sofern die Betreiber, beziehungsweise die Tracker ein öffentlich wahrnehmbaren Hinweis darauf geben und man natürlich kann man widersprechen, aber das ist quasi eine Optout Sache. Erstmal ist das per Defold erlaubt
sofern ein ein öffentlich wahrnehmbarer Hinweis darauf stattfindet. Ähm so das sind ganz.
Gilt das jetzt, gilt das jetzt wirklich auch für dieses für diese Biekens?
War also das das Ding ist halt mein Telefon sendet die ja aus. Und das sendet die wahrscheinlich weiter als ich gucken oder in meinem hohen Alter lesen kann. Das heißt äh sollte mich da jemand warnen ist es schon zu spät.
Sendet die ja wirklich relativ häufig.
Ich ehrlich gesagt
Ist nicht ganz klar, wie die sich das dann konkret vorstellen, aber es könnte zum Beispiel heißen, dass wenn du einen einen Laden betrittst, ein Geschäft betrittst, äh dass das da irgendwie eine Warnung ist. Also irgendwie eine klar sichtbare Warnung steht oder sowas.
Okay, oder oder wirklich erst nach Anmeldung an einen Hotspot, dass der dann sagt, übrigens deine MacAdresse, die speichern wir jetzt und verfolgen dich damit über die gesamte Erde, ähm dass man dann eine Warnung kriegt, okay?
Ja, so das ist grade wenn man sich anguckt wie geht's in dem Feld weiter? Das ist ja ein Feld, das eher oder eine Tracking-Methode, die eher zunehmen wird, das Offline-Tracking ähm ja, also an der Stelle.
Bisschen enttäuschend. Ein weiterer interessanter Punkt ist das Thema staatlicher Zugriff quasi.
E-Prives, die Richtlinie bislang und auch äh so wie die EU-Kommission, die neue E-Privacy-Verordnung äh plant, enthält Öffnungsklauseln, beziehungsweise Ausnahmen für den was die Vertraulichkeit und den Datenschutz in der elektronischen Kommunikation angeht
für die Zwecke der nationalen Sicherheit, Strafverfolgung und so weiter. Äh bislang war da eine explizite Öffnungsklausel für Vorratsdatenspeicherung drinnen
die ist jetzt explizit nicht mehr drinnen, de facto bleibt sie aber bestehen. Das heißt, ähm da gab's zwischendurch mal die Hoffnung, dass da eine explizite ähm
in nachdem der EuGH ja zweitausendvierzehn Vorratsdatenspeicherung eigentlich 'ne Absage erteilt hat. Ähm.
Gab's die Hoffnung, dass jetzt auch in der E-Privace die Richtlinie dann wirklich klar festgestellt wird, es soll keine Vorratsdatenspeicherung geben, das ist nicht so. Stattdessen ist eine Öffnungswerte können die Öffnungsklauseln dafür genutzt werden, dass Nationalstaaten Vorratsdatenspeicherung einführen.
Jetzt wird's kritisch, weil an der Stelle durch den durch die erweiterte Reichweite der,
Der E-Privacy Regeln, so wie sie die Kommission sich vorstellt, nämlich ja nicht mehr nur klassische Telko
Internet und es also Telefonie und SMS sondern jetzt eben auch Messenger und so weiter könnten,
oder werden fest von auszugehen, werden äh Überwachungsfreaks wie Thomas De Maiziere, die das ja sowieso schon lange fordern, das als äh willkommenen Anlass nehmen zu sagen, ah na ja
wenn diese Ausnahmen, die die E-Privacy-Regeln vorsehen, jetzt auch für für Messenger gelten
dann kann ich ja auch die Vorratsdatenspeicherung für Messenger endlich äh einführen in Deutschland.
So ein bisschen tricky.
Das heißt, da kommen wir in den Punkt, da muss was, da müssen wir jetzt gegen VW. Wir haben äh einige Punkte hast du jetzt vorgelesen, wo die Lobbyisten gegen vorgehen werden. Wir wissen, auch einer, wo gegen wir vorgehen.
Für jeden was dabei sozus.
Genau, ja, letzter Punkt vielleicht ähm die Zeit wird knapp, äh aber noch interessant ist das Thema Verschlüsselung. Ähm diverse Organisationen, vor allen Dingen auch der europäische Datenschutzbeauftragte, aber auch die nationalen Datenschutzbeauftragten hatten gefordert, dass dann Recht auf Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung drinnen ist
die EU-Kommission hatte eine Riesenumfrage gemacht in Europa weiter mit siebenundzwanzigtausend
Teilnehmern von den neunzig Prozent gesagt haben, ich muss, ich möchte das Recht darauf haben, ich möchte die Möglichkeit haben, meine Kommunikation so
so zu verschüsseln, dass nur ich und die andere Person auf der anderen Seite,
sie lesen und entziffern können. Also wirklich 'ne überwältigende Mehrheit, ähm, da haben die sich jetzt aber nicht dazu durchringen können, da eine klare Riegel zu reinzuschreiben, sondern steht irgendwo in in einem Erwägungsgrund ähm quasi ein Hinweis,
darauf oder die Bitte quasi an an Hersteller, dass sie ja ihre Kunden auch darüber informieren könnten,
das es Möglichkeiten gibt zu verschlüsseln, aber es steht jetzt zum Beispiel nicht drinnen, ein es gibt ein klares Recht auf Verschlüsselung
auf Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung steht nicht drinnen, dass denn das Recht auf Verschüsselung sozusagen ist ja unter Attacke von auch wieder von Demaziere und anderen. Ähm,
oder was eigentlich richtig geil gewesen wäre,
'ne Verpflichtung an Hersteller oder an Anbieter von Kommunikationsdiensten zu sagen, ihr müsst anbieten, dass die Kommunikation bei euch Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt sein kann,
jede jedes Individuum hat das Recht nur darauf, sondern wirklich eine Pflicht für die Anbieter. So, da steht quasi gar nichts zu drinnen.
So das wären sind auf jeden Fall zwei richtig wichtige Punkte, ähm, wo man jetzt weiter hingucken muss und wie gesagt, es ist nur ein.
Es ist ein Entwurf erstmal, der ist zwei Wochen alt, der sieht wahrscheinlich heute schon nicht mehr so aus oder ist fast drei Wochen alt, äh sieht heute schon nicht mehr so aus, wie wie das, was wir da jetzt gelesen haben und was wir über Politiko erfahren haben
wird in der EU-Kommission gerade abgestimmt und am elften Januar wird der veröffentlicht und dann wird's halt,
richtig rund gehen. Also ich glaube, in Brüssel geht's gerade jetzt schon richtig rund, weil die Trackings ähm ja quasi sagen ist ganz lustig
Die Trackingfirmen sagen jetzt, das Internet, wie wir es kennen ist in Gefahr.
Internet in seinen Grundfesten erschüttern. Ähm.
Sehr schön.
Weil das Internet ja werbebasiert ist und.
Die Basis von allem.
So und an der Stelle muss man A Druck machen, dass die diese tatsächlich guten Schritte, die die das Ding enthält äh,
drin bleiben, dass die umgesetzt werden, dass es in Sachen Vorratsdatenspeicheröffnung für Vorratsdatenspeicherung und Verschlüsselung keine Verschlechterung gibt,
im Idealfall sogar noch Verbesserungen und eigentlich also es gibt jetzt sozusagen Verbesserungen, was das Webtracking angeht, aber das Grundprinzip ähm.
Das Unternehmen ein Tracken dürfen wird damit jetzt nicht beendet, ne? Also es gibt Einwilligungsmöglichkeiten und da wird tatsächlich werden die Rechte ein bisschen verbessert oder würden die Rechte verbessert werden, wenn das so umgesetzt wird, was die Kommission sich vorschlägt, gerade diese Kombi aus
ähm und äh Privacy Bye Design beziehungsweise bei Defold äh ist eine Errungenschaft, die auf jeden Fall drin bleiben müsste.
Alles klar, dann freuen wir uns auf ein äh schönes Quartal eins zweitausendsiebzehn in dem äh da jetzt die blutige Schlacht rumgekämpft werden.
Weil so ein EU-Prozess ist vielleicht nochmal ganz kurz die Kommission macht jetzt einen Vorschlag, dann werden der Rat und das EU-Parlament,
sich das angucken, eigene Vorschläge machen, über Arbeitsvorschläge machen und so weiter, ne? Also das dieser Prozess ist wirklich noch relativ weit am Anfang und das wird im nächsten Jahr, ja, wir würde ich mal sagen, die
Eine der zentralen Schlachten, die es aus äh netzpolitischer Sicht in und aus bürgerrechtlicher Sicht grundrechtlicher Sicht in Brüssel zu schlagen gibt.
Gut, dann bereiten wir uns darauf vor. Bitte. Bitte. Der äh wir kommen zu den Kurznachrichten.
Jaho hat äh seinen eigenen Rekord einfach mal verdoppelt. Äh freiwillig. Äh nicht wahrscheinlich unfreiwillig, aber es war jetzt Tat jetzt keine Not, aber sie haben ihren Rekord.
Quartalszahlen.
Ja, genau, die Quartals.
Sind das die neuen Quartalszahlen.
Quartalszeiten sind so niedrig wie nie zuvor
und dafür haben sie das Datenlieg, was ja jetzt letztens schon mit einer halben Milliarde hatten sie ja den den traurigen Rekord äh schon aufgestellt, aber das reicht ihnen nicht, da sahen sie einfach die Konkurrenz noch zu
zu nah hinter sich und haben jetzt erhöht auf eine Milliarde, äh die ihnen äh irgendwie zwanzig dreizehn.
Verloren gegangen sind, an Nutzerdaten, wissen leider auch nicht, wie die Täter da reingekommen sind. Sie waren nicht in der Lage äh herauszufinden, wie das denn geschehen sein könnte und es scheint wahrscheinlich auch unabhängig
davon zu sein, wie diese halbe Milliarde da irgendwie abhanden gekommen ist und ähm man munkelt, dass wir jetzt gerade seine Optionen sucht, den Kauf dieses Unternehmens rückgängig zu machen, denn da ist ja nicht mehr viel drin,
schon das gesamte Internet hätte. Keine Logbuchfolge ohne auch nochmal eine richtig traurige Nachricht,
es war abzusehen, man hat es eigentlich immer wieder,
sich gefragt, ob Hans-Christian Ströbele nochmal für den deutschen Bundestag antritt. Er hat jetzt bekannt gegeben, dass er für die nächste,
Legislaturperiode, nicht nochmal antreten wird und damit verabschieden wir uns von.
Einem wirklich äh Symbol,
Symbol ein Symbol für deutsche Politik, einem äh einem der ganz klar in die Geschichte eingehen wird und einem Mitglied des NSA-Untersuchungsausschusses
Wer während wir, wenn wir das jetzt nicht schamlos ausnutzen würden, um eine über hundert Folgen alte Folge noch einmal zu bewerben äh bei der Folge einhundert hatten wir Hans-Christian Ströbele zu Gast und ähm
die Folge glaube ich zeigt auch sehr äh umfangreich, äh was das für ein äh Verlust ist. LMP einhundert gehört schon zum Establishment.
Traurig. Aber so ist das Leben eben.
Dauerapfel war. Genau. Womit wir am Ende Sendung angekommen werden.
Das ist immer das Nicken, was ich dann bekomme, die Nüsse darfst jetzt danken. Und zwar der Annemarie, dem Henning, dem Jan, dem Dirk, dem Thomas, dem Christian, dem Matthias, dem Franz Josef, dem Peter, dem Simon Moritz, der Anna und dem Alexander.
Meiner Mama und allen, die mich kennen.
Oh, das ist ja, du wünschst dir was, wenn du hier ein Kessel buntes. Ja und wir danken vor allem auch Ingo fürs Kommen,
Und für deine Ausführung hier zu äh E-Privacy Richtlinie und allen anderen Dingen, zu denen du äh Klughast beitragen könn.
Vielen Dank für die Einladung und vielen Dank, dass ihr dranbleibt. Ich gehe davon aus, dass ihr dann irgendwann im nächsten Jahr äh auf jeden Fall nochmal hoffen, hoffentlich weiterbericht.
Spezial.
Ja, ach so, wir müssen wir müssen vor allem noch äh an dieser Stelle darauf hinweisen, Netzpolitik Ork hat die Jahreszahlen veröffentlicht unter dem schönen Titel äh uns liegen unsere Zahlen nicht nur vor, wir veröffentlichen sie auch äh.
Aktuell sie haben auch ihre gehackten Accounts äh dargelegt.
Ja. Ähm ist noch ein bisschen in den Roten äh das Jahr zwanzig sechzehn, wenn ich das jetzt richtig sehe, ne?
Grundsätzlich ist das so, ja. Also es gibt wir haben mal für so ein Beispiel Monat vor allen Dingen, dass man in so einer echt tollen Grafik ähm visualisieren lassen. Ähm es gibt halt echt
einen richtig tollen, großen Stamm an Dauerspendern, äh aber äh die Dauerausgaben sind halt noch größer und das geht grade noch, weil's eben aus dem letzten Jahr vom Landesverrat noch einen ähm Berg,
der uns gerade noch ein bisschen hilft aber langfristig ist natürlich das Ziel irgendwie.
Sich monatlich durch das zu tragen, durch das, was reinkommt und da ist noch ein bisschen Luft ähm ja.
Der Beispielmonat war da ungefähr sowas wie kostet dreißig reinkommen, zwanzig Defizit von zehn,
So, also wer zehntausend Euro im Monat über hat, bitte einmal hier ganz kurz die Sache klären. Ansonsten müssen wir alle mal äh zehntausend Leute einen Euro dahinwerfen, dann haben wir die Sache auch geklärt.
Genau, sollte dann am Ende tatsächlich noch eine Mark äh übrig sein und ihr auch schon die Wunschliste von äh Linus und mir und äh die Spendenseite der Meter-Ebene abgeklappert habt. Könnt ihr auch nochmal gucken, ob noch ein LNP Supporter Shirt drin ist.
Geht auf Weihnachten zu.
Ja, also wir sind eigentlich jetzt fast alle losgeworden, unseren Restbestand von LMP zweihundert, ein paar sind noch da. Ich habe gerade mal geguckt, ein paar Männershirts gibt's noch. Ich glaube, Damen sind auch schon abgegrast. Ähm der Versand,
äh der Shirts, die jetzt zum genannten Stichtag letzte Woche äh bezahlt worden sind
ist auch schon abgeschlossen, das heißt die Shirts sind auf dem Weg zu euch. Äh wer jetzt noch nachbestellt, kriegt sie erst nach Weihnachten, aber na ja, so ist das halt, das kriegen wir ja sonst nicht mehr organisiert. So oder so
Vielen Dank an alle äh Unterstützer, nicht nur von uns und nicht nur von Netzpolitik Ork, sondern auch überhaupt alle Leute, die sich so in der ganzen äh Podcast-Landschaft, insbesondere
engagieren, da mittlerweile so viele Projekte versuchen, Spenden organisiert über den Winter zu kommen
schon bemerkenswert, dass das zumindest auch im Ansatz möglich ist und wir hier äh eine alternative Medienrealität haben, die unabhängig vom Mainstream sich aufrecht erhalten kann.
Hundert Prozent Fake News frei.
Genau, total. Genug gequatscht, wir sagen tschüss. Und bis bald.
Tschö.